speaking of like you know higher
resolution better technology and stuff
like that I did also see Avatar 2 as
well
we talked about this last time right
yeah we really didn't really go fall
into it yeah yeah yeah I didn't really
get fully into it and what's your rating
I kind of got a lot of [__] for his take
on Avatar I did people would people were
clowning on me for calling it kind of
bit like boring yeah I said the visuals
look good but the story was boring and
I'm like
Connor I agree yeah I agree
put it there I got it I gotta defend
myself agreeing with one another I gotta
defend my boy during his Avatar anyone
who pretends that that story is like
amazing I just don't I I they have to be
Captain like they I don't trust anything
they say because because like I remember
Conor saying that he fell asleep during
like the middle portion of Avatar and
didn't miss anything and I'm just like
gone a monkey moment and I remember
sitting there three hours in and I'm
like [__] I wish I fell asleep the
middle is straight up like nothing like
you don't need to be awake for it right
like at all yeah because I'm like
because
I remember during the middle portion
which was I think the portion that
really like that that was a portion that
was like the hardest to get through for
me
um
let's remake Avatar one but with a new
like new Navi before I start [__] on
Avatar I don't think it's a bad film no
but it's not like the absolute
Masterpiece whatever I don't think it's
a bad film I just I just walked out of
it being like [__] man three that was
three hours of my life holy [__] that
was a long three hours of my life
because uh the middle portion was a very
very
nice Tech demo is what I felt it's it's
it had some of like the most
breathtaking shots I've seen in film
especially in the cinema
um but I'm just like this is this is uh
this is a [__] Sony Bravia Tech demo
that I'm seeing just to show how good
the TV is right now yeah I mean I I
stand by what I said I just think it's
it's it's a good it's a solid movie The
visuals carry a lot of that and the
stories just kind of met yeah because
like I don't really care much for the
characters because I was thinking
there's there's I really really really
want to like Avatar uh yeah me too yeah
because like if like I was I was looking
at it and I'm just like this is this is
almost an isaka you know this is this is
almost an isakai this should be my film
you know Jerry tell me I'm wrong tell me
I'm wrong Joey it just doesn't have the
reincarnation bit but he [__] wakes
up in another world he's he's a totally
different being he doesn't have the
reincarnation but therefore it is
nothing like it is
like the characters did you like that it
was all blue people did you
um you're a fan of blue people I I
[__] hate blue okay
his his money he was like my biggest
problem with Avatar too it wasn't
this it wasn't so much the story it was
the fact that it was three hours long
okay uh because I think round about 30
minutes in I was like I think I know
every major story beat that's going to
happen in this story yeah and I was
completely right everything I thought
was going to happen just happened so
what I'll so in my mind I was just like
okay I know we need to set up the bad
guy and we need to like do this and it's
like a fish out of water but I'm just
here for like I I I knew all of all I
knew all of this was going to happen so
in my mind I was just rushed I was like
kind of like subconsciously wanting it
to rush itself to be like right okay I
know what's gonna happen can we just get
to the payoff that I know you are
setting up because I I know I know
what you need to do to like set up the
bad guy and set up the action scenes or
something like that I'm just like can we
just get to the action scenes faster and
I don't I don't feel like the story kind
of was good enough to be three hours
long to keep me engaged the entire time
to get to the payoff which was like
[__] two two hours in and by that
point I was already mentally very
fatigued so I was I I think fatigue is
the right word because I felt fatigued
watching the middle portion of Avatar
too do you know what I felt like it felt
like a TV series more than it did a film
in some sense yeah I'd say so yeah
because if if this was a TV series I
think I would have enjoyed it more
because it if it was like three hour
long episodes versus just marathoning
three episodes of watch I could I could
have like taken a break in something
like that you basically watched about
six to seven episodes of anime back to
back yeah all right
I watched a season-long anime you could
watch all of Golden Boy in that time
isn't that crazy
yeah because I feel like you know I
could see what he was trying to do with
kind of setting up this family drama and
stuff like that uh and I really really
want to be invested in this world
because one thing I will say is that it
truly got me immersed in this world of
Avatar one thing that I think Avatar's
biggest strength is every time I watched
an iteration of the film you totally get
immersed in this world that James
Cameron has like set up and I think it's
like truly amazing
um that he can get you to like kind of
like yeah immerse you this deeply
because I I don't think I can think of
another film that immerses me this
deeply into another world
um I just wish the story was a bit more
exciting do you feel that way about Dune
did you feel like I felt that way about
Dune as well right
yeah and do not do
Doom is pretty long as well wasn't it
was just over two just over two it's
about two hours it was about two hours I
don't know like Dune didn't feel as long
even though I don't think you had as
many like action set pieces yeah like
not that not that much happened in the
Dune movie yeah I'm just setting up the
worlds but I mean it's [__] epic I
mean it was only the first third of the
first book right yeah yeah because I
think I think the difference between
Dune and Avatar is that they both have
like very very interesting worlds Avatar
just focus Avatar just chooses to focus
on none of the stuff I think is
interesting you know what I mean yeah
like avatars like said like I think the
entire like background premise of
advertised really [__] interesting
like you have um
you have this world where Earth is dying
um and I'm gonna slightly spoil Avatar
too uh but uh the main villain from
Avatar one comes back okay uh because
what happens is that yeah I see I I
didn't like the fact that this was such
an interesting concept that they just
did not [__] utilize at all so what
happens is the main villain from Avatar
one comes back and that's because just
before his final like suicide mission he
stored his memories and sent his
Memories Back To Earth
to be was this like the Matrix yeah yeah
kind of yeah
yeah so his memories is implanted in
this new Avatar right okay I don't think
this is a spoiler because this is
literally in the trailer
um and I that to me that's a [__]
interesting car that's cool the kind of
morality of being like Oh I'm a new
human being who's kind of the clone of
this original one but not really yeah
and I'm like there are so many
interesting [__] Avenues you could
take with just his like just being a
person that is kind of a clone that has
woken up in a [__] alien they could
have gone down like the Ghost in the
Shell right yeah yeah and then he was
just like yeah I'm not I'm not the same
person but I am okay moving on bad
person okay I'm gonna shoot all the blue
people now and I'm like [__] [__] yeah
yeah he doesn't question he doesn't
question anything and I'm like yo if I
woke up as like I guess that's like
maybe his personality that would be the
argument he's so jaded that it doesn't
even crosses he's so militarily focused
I don't know yeah yeah I I too Frank I
wanted him to kill the kids
[Laughter]
I did not like the kids at all I I feel
like it's so hard to make kids likable
in movies yeah because you know the kids
that they're little shits yeah my God I
had no interest in Jake Sully's children
I just did not care no no I I agree I
think one one of the thing that really I
really noticed was that it was three
hours long
um two hours about [__] kids yeah two
hours about [__] kids well not
[__] kids but don't [__] rephrase
that please two two hours about the kids
and
somehow in the two hours I think because
the cast was so big it just didn't
give me enough time it didn't give me
enough time to care about the kids I
don't know
I just weren't likable I don't know with
their personalities there's no amount of
time would make me like that all right I
just I just don't care yeah I just I
just didn't care that's that's my vote
yeah I just it's such an interesting
amazing sci-fi world that James Cameron
has set up and it just God I wish James
Cameron made something else I was I wish
so too I think James Cameron has like a
hard on for water I don't know something
apparently this movie has to break 2
billion to break even yeah which it's
looking like like since since last time
um it's doing pretty well well it's like
it's like 1.7 bill right now I think
yeah isn't that insane though just to
get 2 billion to break even yeah what
insane number God damn man yeah but have
you seen like like James Cameron is like
an incredible filmmaker and I really
like if anyone has seen the behind the
scenes of oh no yes yeah it's insane
yeah it's the it's [__] insane like
you know the amount of times he's just
he's just like wanted to do something
that doesn't exist so he's like I'm just
gonna invent the technology to do it
yeah just because I want to do it in my
film other than this technology just
ends up revolutionizing the entire
[__] film industry again there's just
no slight on him as a director he's
clearly an extremely talented guy and a
genius in films and Technology but man I
just don't care about Avatar
I will still watch Avatar 3 when it
comes out only to see I'm like I'm
watching both these films I guess I'll
just see what happens so here's the
question is it worth after hearing your
guys's opinions on it do you think I
should still go and watch it yeah okay
yes it depends on Avatar three and four
because I remember you gotta have an
opinion on it yeah I kind of want to
have an opinion also don't want to waste
three hours of my life because I I felt
like I'm going to okay so I just watched
like a cliff notes version of it just
should I just watch clips on YouTube go
into the movie an hour and a half in
I'll just be late
I'll spend an hour and a half buying
popcorn getting dinner somewhere and
then I'll just be like oh yeah because
God God damn like some of some of the
imagery in in the middle which uh in the
middle was [__] beautiful but after
about two seasons I was like okay I
understand now it's pretty can we get to
uh can we get back to the story right
um and yeah I said last time that I
don't think the visuals would have you
know it is the best looking film I've
ever seen but I don't I didn't think the
visuals could blow my mind as much as
seeing Avatar one did and yeah that's
how I felt it was it was good but okay
nothing mind-blooded didn't blow my mind
like the first time I saw Avatar one but
that's just because film technology just
looks so good now yeah and it's so hard
okay um James Cameron if you're watching
this which you're probably not you've
made an incredible world and you it's a
world with so much potential for really
interesting ideas that you can take the
story
um
this is my personal opinion if you could
take Avatar three and four in some other
direction other than invading people bad
blue people good then I would I would I
would love that because I really want to
get invest into Avatar I don't think he
has the potential yeah for sure
can you write it can you write an
Instagram please